You're listening to radiolab radio from Wny, C d.
N p. R. [inaudible]
[inaudible]. So we're, um,
we're at church in a church that's different for us.
It's not usually where we start wearing a church cathedral,
really a huge cathedral. Uh, upper Manhattan, St John, the divine God,
an Oregon, the preacher,
preacher, congregation. Of course,
couple of thousand people in the pews. At least Jesus said,
therefore your basic Sunday service
and it's except today you've also got,
here it comes. Oh, no, bizarre.
It's already there.
The reason we began here is because today the church is filled with [inaudible]
dogs. I talked to you about your dog. Yeah. What's his or her name?
His name is blizzard. And what is he? He's a Labrador and put on mix. Wow.
I have legend who I just adopted in January.
I have Jen down bell by the way, in more than dogs.
You've got Burt's name is Jesse. It's a choir now.
And now has this guy ever been blessed before? I don't think so.
Me just warn this year in Hamsters, his name is TBI,
teddy toes. And if he'd come out you'd see why?
Because he's really fat and all kinds of creatures.
Got a little girl with a Falcon and behind her, oh, it's a giant cordis. This is
the Saint Francis Day of the animals.
So the yearly event and coming toward us when people bring their animals to be
blessed. Is it daunting? The folks that are gathered here,
there was a little girl with a hermit crab.
They don't think there's anything weird or inappropriate about this fact.
If you ask them in, here comes a bull, here's what they say.
I don't know if it means anything to her, but it means that to me.
Cause you know you want to baptize your babies and this is more or less the same
kind of thing. And what is it? What does it mean to you? It just means when,
when she finally does go away, she's going to, uh, but I haven't,
what kind of parent it is? She called core goals. Oh yeah.
Don't put your hand near his face. If he wants his new chuckled struggle.
Do you feel like he has a soul or an inner life of some sort?
It's a thinking being there. They're as smart as we are. Really? Yeah.
Since you invited me here, I didn't want to be impolite or anything.
Say what you got to say. Wow. Okay. These people, of course,
they love their animal. Sure. Yeah. Did you hear that?
That's when I'm feeling sad.
Comes in the bed and he lays down spine to spine with me and he just didn't
leave my side. Bye. They piss you off a little bit.
That the animals they love are going to feel just the grace of the prayer or
feel
the blessing, which is a, which raises a question,
what do we really know about what goes on inside the animal's mind?
Yeah. All those things that you might feel in a church. Grace, gratitude, uh,
guilt. Can the animals feel those things too?
How much can we share and can you measure it? Yeah.
I'm Jad Abumrad I am Robert Krulwich. This is radio
[inaudible]
well, and we'll begin the hour with a story about an animal who would,
I'm sure love to have been at the worship service, but it was,
it was a very inconvenient thing. Didn't quite get there.
[inaudible]
okay. Just to get things rolling.
This is a story that we heard about [inaudible] enough to talk about first from
the falling. Hey, is it makers? Mike [inaudible]. I go by Mick.
There's way too many mikes around. Mick Migos,
his name here and then we met nick recently at the Emeryville Marina,
which is not far from San Francisco where he's got a boat called the super fish
figured out. Make says he rents out for all kinds of things.
It's your trips to ash gathering bachelor parties, fireworks watching.
I don't know. I get a little cardboard sign. I stand by the freeway.
Just have boat need work. So yeah,
that's Mick and our story begins one morning in December,
probably eight o'clock in the morning or something.
As I recall a few years back [inaudible] just kind of sitting at home.
I was at home. Yeah, it was the middle of December. We didn't have any work,
but then he gets this call. Hello, you got this call there.
Is it call relaying a message from a fisherman way out at sea,
18 miles maybe outside the golden gate bridge.
They told me that there was a whale in trouble,
tangle up in grab gear and it didn't appear to be able to move.
So after he hangs up, make immediately calls a few dive buddies, Jim Young,
Jim Young, air force pararescue. And then let's see, James Mosquito,
James Mosquito national diver. I called them and said, hey, you know,
here's the deal. Are you interested? It was a no brainer. I said, yeah, I'm in.
Absolutely. All right, we're going. I packed up my stuff,
I have my gear and I went directly to the boat and we left underneath the Golden
Gate Bridge.
Nothing that the horizon in front of us. My name is Holly [inaudible].
I am James's significant other. We motored out for about two hours.
I had to do west towards the Carolinians.
What were you feeling when you're on the boat heading out?
I didn't think we'd find her. I really didn't.
But about 18 miles off the coast, completely open water.
One of the divers spots and crab buoys in the distance and some seagulls flying
overhead. And as they got closer, why saw the whale?
She just, uh, just the very
top of the whale sticking up about maybe six inches out of the water at the
surface, a tiny sliver of black. That was it. I said, okay,
we need it. See what's going on. So, uh,
so Tim and James Jump into an inflatable boat and they paddle about a couple
hundred feet from the whale and it just wasn't happening.
Every time that the swale came on up,
it would just displace the boat back again. So it pushed us back again,
not to mention the visibility in the water was just terrible.
He couldn't even see down there to see, you know, what they were dealing with.
And, uh, you know what, sometimes plans have to change in, in mid flight.
So Tim and James Look at each other and without saying a word, boom,
we got out of the boat and slash
until the water
and I see a shadow
[inaudible] this massive animal, a hazy silhouette.
And we just started swimming
[inaudible]
to the whale about a hundred feet away, uh,
you know, parts of, of blubber and skin floating around 35 feet,
20 feet. And then they see it.
My goodness, this thing's the size of a school bus.
A female humpback whale is one of the largest creatures on the planet,
50 feet long, 50 tons,
and this particular whale was in a kind of c shape where its head was at the top
of the water, but its tail was almost pointed directly down.
It was almost like somebody was pulling her down by the tail to the bottom of
the ocean. Yeah, there was probably 20 crab traps,
2000 pounds at least just tied up to the tail.
She had just become an anchor and to see her not be able to move that tail and a
struggle,
the will was actually really laboring to breathe a little puff and there was
just a rope everywhere.
It went around the whales mouse around the whales head across her eye,
over her background, the pictorial fins all way down to his tail.
I thought there was no hope, there was no chance.
We're looking at a dead well and the whale just doesn't know it yet.
But I knew that I had to try when a swim to the whale.
And as soon as I decided, okay, I'm gonna swim to the whale.
Well the whale decided she wasn't going to have that.
What'd she do? She put up her tech Toro Fin,
which is like her arm and this pictorial fins about 15 feet long.
It's about four feet wide. And she just
splashed down the water in front of me. You know,
this is the size of an airplane wing coming down on top of you,
just inches from my head.
So at that point I backed off and uh, waited,
waited for the whale to settle down. She was exhausted,
which he did. And then they both swim back.
James goes to the tail and Tim, up to the wheels head, you know,
I was there with a a six inch dive knife cutting out line right near her eye,
which was the size of a grapefruit hinge. Her eye was moving,
keeping an eye on [inaudible].
Really? Yeah, absolutely. He would go left or I would go left,
he'd go right or I would go right. She was tracking me.
And all the while they're just cutting as much rope as they can.
You really had a saw at it. It was very strong, very tight.
Sometimes I'd cut a rope and it would be a loose rope and all of a sudden
something else would tighten up,
which was the one rope that would let it all free. This whole process took
hours, but finally James gets to the end of it.
He's at the tail sign his way through that big clump of line and he realizes at
a certain point it to cut through all that line when they have to stab
the whale to get my knife underneath the rope. Ah, it was that tight though.
I, uh,
Jad my knife into the whale's tail and pulled the rope and then cut it and it
wants the rope went.
It was a very surreal moment looking down and seeing the 20 crab traps and buoys
just disappear into the abyss.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
and just like that the whale was gone.
I'm spinning around going, where'd she go? Where'd she go?
But as the waters settled, they realized they'd done it. They'd freed her.
As soon as I came up, I was like, Woo. Oh. Cooping it up and yelling.
Unbelievable.
Well, I was screaming, can you imagine it
now? Here's where the story takes a pretty startling turn. In fact,
the whole reason we wanted to tell this story to begin with,
it's for what happens next.
So Tim and James and the other divers are in the water. They're celebrating,
high fiving, and then all of a sudden
James looks down.
Next thing I know how I have this 50 ton whale coming right at me.
I'm thinking, oh my God, stop. I just stayed. Wait,
so this whale is coming at you from below like jaws. Yeah,
she's rising up towards me. Oh God. And I was just thinking,
this is going to hurt.
Yeah. When she was only inches away from my chest,
[inaudible] stopped and
push me on the chest backwards
and then released me and then kind of pushed again
and then released and pushed again and again. Wow.
And then she swam up right next to me,
picks her head up above the water so that her eye was above the water.
And then came up and looked directly at me
[inaudible]
and for what felt like 30 seconds.
He says she just
stared at him. The pupil didn't move around.
She wasn't looking for anything else. She was just looking
at me. [inaudible]
you're in the presence of something that great, makes you feel small.
It really wasn't a very emotional feeling. No,
it wasn't quite sure what to make out of it,
make of it. But then he says she went off to the next Dyer did the same thing.
I remember distinctly,
I was 18 inches away from her eye and she just looked at me and let me touch
her.
Okay.
And then swam off and then she went off to the next diver and did the same thing
and the next person and did the same thing one by one coming up Brian next to
him looking at him really good and you know, inches away. Eyeballing them.
Just swam around to every diver, all the guys.
So it was about desk. Um, the water was glass flat.
I was sitting at the helm of the boat just in awe and they had to leave the
whale. She didn't want to leave them.
And this is a real question here.
What exactly was that wheel doing or saying? Was she saying anything?
If you ask James or Tim or Mike or any of the other divers that were in the
[inaudible]
water that day,
Neil tell you I felt this well was really thanking us.
I know it sounds crazy, but I could see the look in her eye,
this mammal, this,
this 50 ton mammal was literally saying thanks,
thanks for helping me out. And you know, I'll,
I'll bring that to my grave knowing the gratification that I felt
[inaudible] [inaudible]
so what do you think? Here's the question really.
Was that whale saying thank you? Was the whale thing?
Well I think the whale was things, something, I mean a whale.
If she was just free of her ups, I would think she would just go off and say,
well I'm free. So the fact that she was,
she hung around and make these specific eyeball visits, like,
I don't know. I feel that she, there's something intentional about that.
She didn't leave anyone out, right? No, she went, in fact, according to them,
one of the guys on the boat,
she actually went to the boats and did the same thing to the boats.
She said thank you to the boats. Yeah.
Well then so she was looking at the people,
but she also thought that the craft was somebody she had to say that or say deal
with. Yeah, so maybe she was just cite. Maybe she was just a,
yeah,
I really don't know what I mean. I,
I don't feel completely comfortable just saying,
of course I know what I want to feel. Yeah, me too.
But let's just try to straighten up for a second.
We have a guy named Clive when his teaches at the university. Hey. Oh, hi.
Is this Mr Clive when, yeah, this is live when Clive is with them.
Psychology Department of the University of Florida. Where am I taught?
Here's this, this is Jad from my radio 11 right. Hijab.
Clive also happens to be an expert on animal psychology and this is Robert also.
You hear US pretty well? I can hear you pretty well. I'm, I'm,
I'm wondering how well I'm going to distinguish your voices. No need to do that.
This as a unitary figure. Okay. Listen, let me,
let me begin on this is Robert Talking will tell you a story and we want to know
what you think of the story. So once upon a time and not too long ago,
we're going to fast forward a bit because we ran Clive through the entire wheel
story front to back question to you is if a diver said to you,
this will said thank you to me, what would you say?
Well,
I would be put in a difficult situation because I don't doubt that what these
people experienced was a very moving moment with that whale.
But the problem is I just don't speak whale,
so I don't know what thank you looks like in whale.
If I'm going to be a cynic about it, I would say,
well the whale has been trapped for I believe,
over a day and may just be disoriented.
Well, but this was,
this was parking herself with one individual and then moving to the next.
That's not a distracted. That looks like it's got some money intention.
It shows some interest in the individuals. I'll give you that, but how do we,
how do we get from that too?
Did you sing that the whale is trying to express things? What do you live in?
Let's play a different example.
Let's suppose that you found a bear in the woods that was caught up in some
netting that ended up in the woods and you work for hours to free the bear and
then the bear eats you.
Does that mean that the the bears are an ungrateful species of animal? Yes.
No, I don't really believe that. Well, so,
so I mean it would make as much sense to ascribe in gratitude to the bear as it
does to ascribe gratitude to the whale.
I just don't think that's a useful way of trying to understand animals.
I think it ultimately it demeans them because it means that instead of living in
a world that's full of a diversity of wonderful creatures,
each with its own ways of relating to other members of its own species and other
members of other species, we say, well, we don't live in a world like that.
We live in a world that's basically a world of human beings. It doesn't matter.
Some of these human beings have suits on some of these human beings weigh
hundreds of tons and live under the ocean and can hold their breath for a very
long time. None of that really matters. Ultimately,
they're all basically like us and I just don't find that satisfying.
Are you saying that you don't know if there's a possibility of sharing or that
you don't think that there's a possibility of sharing at an emotional level
between two species? Um,
I don't doubt that there is the possibility of sharing between two species.
I mean, I see it with dogs all the time, but I think the,
it will be a mistake if we thought that the love we feel for our dogs is the
same feeling that the dog has back to us. It,
it has different qualities and it's where you pet your dog wags his tail and it
seems happy to see you. Yeah. Do you just like not trust that well, okay,
so let me make clear that I wear two hats when I'm talking about a dog,
particularly a pet of my own.
I'm where I have two possible hats I can wear and one is that when the dog pants
back at me, I just hugged the dog and you know, let him kiss me and that's,
that's life with a dog. But if I'm,
if I'm now wearing my scientific hat and getting my blanket as wet as I possibly
can, then I ask myself, what did these behaviors mean among those?
That was a beautiful study that came out recently from Alexander Horevitz.
I'm Alexandra Horowitz and I study dog cognition. Where do we find her?
She's well, she's around the corner from you. She's at Barnard College.
So we sent our producers, so we're in wheeler. Yep. That's me to meet her.
And he ended up hanging out with her and her dog Finnegan in the park.
Snuffle that's nice stuff.
She did this beautiful experiment that shows that, um,
when people think their dog is looking guilty,
eyes lowered tail between the legs.
Actually the dog is just being submissive.
So here's what she did. She tracked down a bunch of dog owners,
posted 'em craigslist and put out posters and she found a bunch of owners who
believed that like most dog owners do that their dogs feel guilt. Yes,
my dog feels guilty when he's done something wrong.
And then she set up a situation where all of the dog owners had to scold their
dogs because you know, they had been told that their dogs did something bad.
But the trick of the experiment is that only half the dogs had done something
wrong.
Half the dogs had actually been naughty and half the dogs had not been naughty.
But then she misinformed the owners lied to half of the owners to the owners.
So even the owners who has dogs hadn't been bad,
thought their dogs had been bad,
so everybody scolded their dog and almost everyone did this the same way,
which was to say no that lead to their dogs and maybe put their hands on their
hip and expressed as pivotal. Yes. Then again,
oh, it's okay.
See fitting just made the look even though he hadn't done anything wrong.
And that's essentially what she found.
Even the non guilty dogs need the guilty look.
It didn't matter whether the dog had transgressed or not.
All that mattered was whether it was being chastised by it's owner. So bad dog,
bad dog. Right. That creates the look, not the deed. That's exactly right.
But, but for me, the,
the pivotal question here is not whether or not they all had the look,
but what's attached to that?
Look what feeling in the dog is attached to that guilty look.
Maybe the dogs who were falsely accused still felt bad.
Well, maybe they did. Maybe they didn't have.
Maybe there are angels on top of this control console here.
[inaudible]
I thought it was a perfectly valid question. Yeah, we should think, uh,
Alexandra Horowitz, her latest book is called inside of $8.
[inaudible]
and before we end this section,
I have we resolved the question of what was that whale doing with those people?
Was she saying thank you or no? No. And do we ever resolve any questions at all?
Well we try, we give a little closer to the, we got this, no,
we have not resolved but we will try harder but, but, but,
but in our next section, a mere 70 seconds away,
we will try very hard to actually get scientific about it.
Hi, this is Tim young out in California, uh,
on my first take of leading the radio lab credit. So here it goes.
Radio lab is funded in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation and the National
Science Foundation. Hi,
this is five when radio lab is produced by WM YC and distributed by NPR.
Hi,
it's Rachel Martin from NPR news up first is the morning news podcast from NPR.
When news moves fast,
it's the quick morning update on what happened and what you need to start your
day. The most important news in about 10 minutes or so.
Wake up with up first every day.
You can find it by 6:00 AM eastern time on the NPR one app or wherever you
listen to your podcast.
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab today is our animal minds animal mind, right? Do can,
can one animal really know what's going on in another animal's head? Yeah.
Like really? No really, no thanks for meetings.
So we were thinking about that whale story that we heard before the break,
you know,
where the divers make the whale and they were sure that we always saying thanks,
literally saying thanks. Thanks for helping me out. Okay.
That is their opinion. But we wanted to know like,
what can you actually scientifically say about that kind of exchange and that
question. Let us introduce yourself. Like, so this guy, uh,
my name is Patrick Ho.
I am a neuroscientist at Mount Sinai School of Medicine in New York,
although actually the truth is he's really from someplace like Geneva.
He's from, he's a Swiss from the French part of Switzerland. Right. Um,
we came to him because he may have found a way of separating the animals,
of knowing which animals can genuinely have human emotions and which can't.
It's, it starts,
it starts in 1995 we were studying the anatomy of the human cingulate cortex.
It's part of the brains right here, Kenny, between your eyes,
butt down and a student in my lab as an chain scheme.
She was looking at some brains and she saw something, ah,
these very slender of bipolar on the run.
I've never seen a neuron like that. Maybe it's unknown months,
probably pathological, just to be sure.
She got some slides of other human brains looked in the same place. And we,
there was again,
started to see them again and we were very pleased. Say, okay,
we have discovered a new cell type, whew.
Something that is unique to human.
But then they went to the library and discovered that some guy whose name is a
Constanta Fun Economo [inaudible] Romanian guy.
[inaudible] had seen these cells 70 years ago and you named them spindle cells
because of their shape. Oh, that must've been a very sad day for Esto. No, no,
no.
It's now they believe that these little brain cells may be a key to how humans
relate to one another and whether or not other creatures can relate to us in the
same way. Right. Is it possible to,
for us to see a spin the cell? Yeah, we can. We can show you a spin. Also,
Patrick Hoff took us down the hall. Yup.
Jag went first and parked him in front of it.
Big Microscope. Yeah, fine sense. Again, look at it. Will it be obvious to me?
Yeah. I'm looking at crossing the middle of the field.
You can see a series of tall, slender and making me dizzy. One, two,
three, four, five. Is that the spindles? Yeah. Oh, they're everywhere. Yeah.
Aw. You want to see them when you can see them? I mean, yeah. You hold in mind.
Oh yeah. There's like a,
there's a whole troop of them and they're long and skinny and purple.
It's funny because the normal brain cells,
which you can also see in there are like that,
but these ones are do like little purple bananas,
like a team of Purple Banana and the thing that makes these cell so interesting,
she means to hit off in this direction. Yeah. According to Patrick Hoff is that,
you know, in the normal brain cells they just talk to their neighbors.
But these ones, because they're so long,
they seem to be yelling across a big a distance. Exactly.
We know that this sales send an action at some distance. Okay.
Hello?
[inaudible]
it's across the valley. Yeah, it's across the valley. Exactly. It's projecting
the projecting what and from where to where. Well,
Patrick Hoff doesn't entirely know,
but he says he can make it pretty good guess based on, well,
if you look in the microscope, you do notice the things.
Yeah. Yeah. So, so here, here,
top of the spindle points toward the surface of the brain or your job, he says,
seems to shoot up towards those more modern parts of the brain that involve high
Yoda cognition, language, abstract thinking.
Whereas the bottom of the spindle seems to shoe down
deep down lower centers in the brain towards those older parts of our brain that
involve
feelings, emotions, instinct.
So perhaps this is what Patrick off things,
the desales are a kind of network,
a really important one did allows the different parts of our inner selves
connect.
Like you've got the parts of us down here that feel things can now communicate
with the parts of us up here that think things.
This is an oversimplification of course, but the point,
the larger point is that this is exactly what happens when you look into the
eyes of another human being because it begins with a kind of thought,
your eyes seem sad,
but then that thought within you travels a great distance and connects with a
feeling of sadness that you feel sad too.
I mean it's the basis of a kind of a emphasis.
Exactly. Exactly. You know, I, I see you are happy, you know, so,
so that I feel good about it and you know, and consider those times.
I mean not just empty where like your thoughts and feelings are in conflict and
if you've got to really talk to one another. Like for example,
when you kicked in front of me at the microphone yet again and hey it's you,
but I know that I have to work with you. So I, I sit on that feeling,
I just sit on my, it's going down to the bottom of my brain,
but I say take a nap.
See that's the best part of your spindle situation is that it's not just a
thought to connect to feelings with his thoughts can sometimes suppress
feelings. Yeah.
I think that's the idea is that humans in social interactions can rely on these
hardwired emotions in the same way. Either animals might be able to,
that's shown hilarious science writer,
a regular radio lab contributor and a guy we often call it to help us make sense
of things. Um, you know,
we can like a dog just hump every other dog and see what happens.
We've just got a flirt and be funny and you know,
buy a couple drinks and that, that, that was, you guys have to cut that cause I,
I am so astonished. We kind gotta use that.
I just, I just turned into a frat boy. So,
but the point being that our social interactions are very complicated and that
we can't rely,
it's much tougher for humans to rely on simply these hardwired primitive
instincts against the job of spindle cells is to simply broadcast
content to the rest of the brain. Cause without our whole brain involved,
we'd never be able to navigate the social world and make any kind of connection.
Right.
So if spindle cells then allow us to talk gently and emotionally to one another.
The question is, this is the question for our hour,
what about introduced species is intra or inter intra intra run net?
Yeah, that's inside I think across species is what you mean.
Does any other animal have spindle cells?
Yeah, we're taking and as it happens, so we, I'm you to my cold
room just down the hall from his office. It's professor Hoff has a freezer,
a way high stalled.
The specimens are very big door to full.
The brain's going to get to the cooler here.
All different kinds with brains of volume species. The CETACEANS are over there.
We have the Great Davis around whale wall and that's the way the wall, yeah,
he's got dozens and dozens of brains and buckets and new jars and it keeps them
all organized. Well in each category of species has its own shelf.
You have more grapes down there with going laws in orangutans.
Uh, it was really cold in there too.
What they did was they took a bunch of those brains off the shelf and walked him
down the hall to the lab and put little pieces of them under a microscope.
They didn't expect to find any of those bizarro neurons,
any of these other creatures.
Cause he was pretty sure this is something that is unique to human.
But one day we will looking at the brain of the Humpback Whale
and we stumble on spindle cells, plenty of spindle cells. Oh,
so what was that? Did you, were you surprised? And I was there say, okay,
this is fascinating. You weren't expecting that. I wasn't expecting that.
But on the other hand, here we have the, the humpback whale,
which is a very social animals. They, they,
they form clans, they,
they communicates the males. It was so long
they hunt together. They develop punting strategies,
which requires perfect coordination of many whales.
So they have to act together to do that.
Now if acting together is the key, you know,
and having complex social structures,
well then these things shouldn't just be limited to Wales. And in fact,
over the years half and other scientists have found spindle sales in
chimpanzees, elephants, dolphins,
gorillas. Which begs the question
[inaudible]
like if we want to have an experience with another creature and now not just at
the zoo, but are real shared experience,
do those creatures need to have these things?
Do you think the existence of spinned Osos creates more of a possibility of
having that cross species sharing moment? I think so.
[inaudible]
if we assume that the cells have zilch an influence on uh,
the sociability of the species,
it is very likely that you would, uh,
experience something of that kind of with the species that has them.
I doubt you would get a very good experience if you were trying to do this with
the Hyena.
So maybe what we see when we look into, you know,
these sad eyes of a blue whale or when we look into the eyes of an elephant,
I'm cradling a baby elephant, which are just the cutest things on earth.
Maybe what we recognize is, is, is that same flavor from ocean,
that same inner life, a feeling maybe,
and it's the big maybe maybe that in our life requires spindle cells.
And how big is that? Maybe it makes, it sounds like a really maybe, maybe.
I mean, you know, it's important that I, this is all just a,
I think this is still very theoretical and in fact if you asked people like
Clive with the fellow who, who, who poo-pooed our whale, thank you from before,
ask Clive. Like,
could you look at an animal and find something in the animal that says, Yep,
if he has that he's got feeling well wrong.
I don't for a moment imagine that there's going to be a type of nerve cell or a
type of structure in the brain,
which is going to be such an acid test of whether an animal has a particular
psychological capacity that we could then find that kind of neuron and say,
well, now we know without having to look at the behavior of the animal.
Now we know that this species has this or that psychological ability. Well,
let me ask the question a different way. I mean,
do you think spindle cells are no spindle cells?
Let's just toss them out for a second.
Do you think there are a category of creatures that are more likely to have
empathic experiences with us? Would you draw lines between beings? Well,
the thing I would, the,
the thing I would emphasize if we're looking for empathy between different
species is there, um,
developmental experiences to make his point.
Clive told us about this experiment is let's take a chimp with all the spindle
cells inside the chimp brain there.
Put the chimp in the room and in front of the chimp,
let's put the two cops face down. No one of the cups has a grip,
something delicious under it,
and the chimp doesn't know where the grape is. It could be under cup a cup B.
So what you,
the experiment you do is you simply point to the cup that has the grape.
Like that's the one, that one right there.
And all the animal has to do is to go to the cup. That's pointed to it.
Seems simple enough. But chimps five says,
chimps find this stunningly difficult to understand. Get this wrong.
What do you mean? I mean,
they just look at you pointing and they look at your pointing and they look and
you're pointing and they just go, Whoa,
where is dogs who don't have spindle cells?
Most pet dogs get this from the get go.
The dogs can do this and chimps can, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They quite spontaneously recognize that you should go where where they point and
Clive says the explanation here is not the dogs have some special cell in their
brain. It's simply because because they grow up in our households,
they grow up with us. Right to test this idea. He did the same study,
the pointing one. Yup.
Except this time with some wolves because wolves are the animals from which dogs
are descended but they haven't lived in human households obviously and normally
like the chimps.
Wolves totally screw up the pointing tasks that we've done some tests on some
wolves that were hand reared by human beings and are very friendly to human
beings and we find that those wolves behave just like the dogs,
that they are just as good at following the human pointing to find the food.
Really. Did you have to train them or no? We did not train them.
They just wound up while they just picked it up.
But these are exceptional bowls in so far as they were reared by human beings.
They were bottle fed when they were wee babies because there are things that go
on earlier in our development that are crucial and that include learning who are
your, who are your kind, what do I, who am I, what am I?
And you learn that in a critical period in your early life by looking around you
and seeing who you're interacting with.
Pretty much every dog you might meet has learned to accept humans as social
companions. And that's because it was written in a human home.
And because evolution has prepared it with a relatively slow development so that
it's pretty easy to tame a dog. The Wolf on the other hand,
it goes through its childhood and adolescents in the blink of an eye in the
course of just a handful of weeks.
And so it's actually extremely difficult to successfully hand rear a wolf
because you have so little time available to you and you have to invest 24 hours
a day,
seven days a week during that brief period that a wolf is open to the
possibility of learning who its companions might be. That's really interesting.
You know, one of the pieces of the interpretation that I find intriguing,
I wanna I want to run by you. Is that, Ooh, so interesting.
I'm now sitting here thinking, boy, if I could raise a whale with a baby bottle,
then I would know whether the will was saying thank you to me because I would
have learned it's not like I have to learn a little bit.
Whale would have learned human. Wow, that's right. I mean,
of course this is completely hypothetical.
The whales are really bad example to choose,
but my guess would be if you bottle fed or whale,
you would get a whale that might plausibly do something like a behavior that
expresses things. That is such a hard mental image to conjure. Well,
that's right. That's right.
Bottle feeding away because we have to keep rising to the surface for 21 years
to breathe before I actually get to the experiment.
There are a number of drawbacks to that experience.
Radio will continue in a moment.
My name is Mike [inaudible] or Radiolab listener in Singapore.
Radiolab is supported in part by the National Science Foundation and by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology in the modern world.
For more information about Sloane, go to www dot [inaudible] dot org
hey, I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich Radiolab today. Uh,
kind of a hard topic to describe. We're calling it, um, animal minds animal,
or maybe the better way to say this is minds other than our own,
which would be the animals. No, we're, we're animals though. Yeah, you're right.
Yeah. So we live with, yeah. Wherever.
You weren't having enough trouble just talking to each other.
But imagine if I would try, if you were a Labrador, that'd be tough. See,
then we'd have a problem or a way. That's kind of what we're looking at it.
How much can you really share with, you know, a Labrador or a whale. Right.
And we're not solving this problem in this show at all,
but we really could do this.
Maybe instead of talking to scientists about other minds,
maybe we should talk to, um, a writer. Yeah. Paul, can you hear me?
Paul, can you hear Paul Paul, Paul Paul,
the writer we chose to look for you may not know was named Paul. Okay, standby.
Paul. He's the author of any number of travel books,
novels. Did he win a big prize? I'm sure. Yes. Is that Jed? Yes.
Hi j d, that's me. Like a Pulitzer, one of the,
one of the big ones and I didn't win a Pulitzer,
but he won a prize of my heart when he wrote the Patagonia Express. Oh,
so you're taping. Okay, great. Yes, yes. Anyhow,
Paul Theroux travels all around the world writing about all kinds of things,
but the reason we called him is for something that actually happened in his
backyard, which luckily for him happens to be in the state of Hawaii.
I own seven acres on a slope,
a west facing slope on the north shore of Oahu. O and I had very,
very long grass and someone said, oh, I know what you need is some geese.
They'll take care of that grass.
So I called a couple and you decided not to go to the hardware store and buy a
lawnmower. You decided to buy two animate bird? That's right. I would have deed.
So I really, really serious industrial mower.
Instead I get to nonindustrial geese.
Oh,
I actually got three two Gander's in a goose and the strange thing happened,
one of the candies imprinted on me.
So what does that mean?
Show me the baby chick boy looked at you as 10 the first moving thing they see
is the mother figure. This goose became very attached,
very protective. It would sit by lap. When another goose came up,
it would peck at them. Anyway,
it was both protective and attentive,
but as the gander grew up,
strange things began to happen. First it became detached from me,
then aggressive toward me and then needed me.
It was very strange and it made me think,
I want to get some more geese and I want to read more about them and then and
then watch them. So he, well, he asked friends and friends said to him, look,
if you want to know everything that's important to know about geese,
you have to read e
B white. Most people mentioned ab white when they talk about gays and our costs.
I know and love Ab White.
And if you're not a Martian you probably love Eby too. I mean,
what do you mean? And being people,
it's possible for people not to love read Stuart little or how many people read
Charlotte's web? Just if you don't love the children's fiction.
And he's certainly one of the great greatest of all American SAS. Yeah,
see that's the point. He's one of the great American writers. He actually
wrote the Bible for writing elements of style. You know,
let's tell the Bible for writing weirdly. And it was written like 50 years ago.
So when people point to anything by BYG you point seriously.
And in this case, very late in life, after he'd moved up to a cabinet in Maine,
he was in his seventies and this particular essay we're gonna talk about is
called very simply the geese, the geese,
Allan Cove, July 9th, 1971
okay.
I've had a pair of elderly gray goose goose and the gander living on this place
for a number of years and they have been my friend.
So Paul threw open the essay early in the spring,
fully expecting to learn all about geese.
But then he kept running across these little phrases and adjectives that made
him
cringe. [inaudible] he talks about a Gosling that grows into,
I'm quoting now, a real, real dandy full of pompous thoughts.
Surely gesture, pompous thoughts and surly gestures, you know, come on. I mean,
doesn't that make the goose a little bit more, um, easy to relate to? All right,
take one word malice.
I could not tell whether the look in his eye was one of malice or affection.
Bellis is a word you use for Mussolini or somebody else from dos.
But what's the sin in that?
If a man who's a professional storyteller and one of the greatest ones, it says,
let me tell you about my keys.
And then talks about them as though they were uncles and aunts and neighbors
with moods that are distinctly human. Well,
I suppose you could say so. You could say so what if you put them in,
you know little Halloween costumes too for that matter. So what,
but I'm in the writing business. Thriving business should be unsparing.
He could be quite unsparing himself in his writing.
You're giving Evie white too much license.
If you're saying it really doesn't matter, it does matter to me
and the reason it matters is Paul through
is it Eby got so attached to the idea of those geese as aging critters like
himself did.
He missed something deep and important about the geese.
The elements of that behavior that is,
that is pure groups all pointed to the end of it. Suddenly
I heard sounds of a rumble outside in the barnyard where the ganders were
formerly great gander gets unseated by a younger male. Goose is a big fight.
It's a squawking and the old gander loses
[inaudible].
I watched as he threaded his way slowly down the narrow path between clumps of
pistols and daisies. His head was barely visible above the grasses,
but his broken spirit was plain to any eye.
I felt very deeply his sorrow and his defeat. Well,
the defeated a Ganda goes off. Well, this isn't true at all.
When aganda loses a battle, he goes off,
gets his strength back and waits for a chance to attack again.
That kind of is going to come back and fight again.
So you're saying that he got it wrong? Of course. Of course.
Here's a man who is solitary.
He's a New Yorker who goes to Maine and becomes a gentleman farmer of a kind
and begins to relate to his case and then writes about them as though he's one
of them. I know I'm not one of them, but if you can't use words that are,
you know, very human and psychological words,
and if you can't because you're not a goose,
have whatever it is that geese have on their insides,
then what if you wanted to share something with a goose,
and I bet you you do.
Is there any way in which you could honestly describe yourself as a friend of
any of these gates?
I would say, you know, the, the, this is a very good question. I,
I had a very surly tend to use it. Eby were a very, uh, very,
um, rambunctious Ganda and he got very sick. You know,
the thing is sitting on the ground just following its nest.
I thought he was really gonna die and I nursed him back to health.
I gave him a, a antibiotic with a Turkey based, uh,
and it took about three or four weeks.
And the first thing he did when he was nurse back to health, he was,
he got up on two legs and I came up with the Turkey based to give him one last
drink. And he bit me and I thought, Pop Lady Lady,
he bit my leg hod. And I thought, okay, he's back to hell. You didn't think Al
could you? Well, I thought he said he's, he's healthy,
he's healthy again and he's behaving just as a goose or don't you see though
that if the moment of true of your true most goosey moment is the moment when
you're with the goose that you help bites you,
then you are out of this story in effect.
I, I absolutely agree with that. In, in all of this, there's an implied, uh,
loneliness.
I'm not his friend. I'm not a feathered creature.
I'm a human being among birds.
I'll vote curiously.
Paul Theroux does have an approach to communing with his keys.
He takes a chair, puts it on the lawn, plops down in the chair
and disappears. You know,
my writing day ends or the early afternoon I have lunch and after lunch there's
a long sunny period in the afternoon when I'm alone,
I'm with the case and I sit around with them and try to make out what they're
doing among each other and paying no particular attention to meet.
It's simply watching the world as it was.
You're seeing creatures who are behaving as though cities don't exist.
Presidents don't exist. Governments don't exist.
Roads don't exist as if it's before the fall. Hmm.
Well as though it's the peaceable kingdom,
simply watching animals who are content doing their thing.
Then you feel a bit like Adam
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible]
[inaudible]
Radiolab is produced by Jad Abumrad and Foreign Wheeler,
Michael Raphael,
Ellen Horn and Lulu Miller with help from addy Nerium and Tim Howard.
Special thanks to Brianna Brene and Kelly Carmody.
Apologies for portraying anything.
Wait a second, stop. Stop the machine.
It just feels weird to end the show this way with this lonely geese thing.
So we're going to play for you. One final story. It's kind of a continuation,
uh, of Paul through in his geese,
except involves a very different guy in a very different climate. First of all,
who would, who are you, what's your name?
My name is Paul Nicklin and I'm a contributing photographer to National
Geographic magazine. Paul Nicklin is basically national geographics, Arctic guy.
It's,
I've been pegged as their polar specialist and this particular tale involves his
attempt to photograph one of the Great Arctic predators, the leopard seal,
leopard seal, which by reputation is a very nasty creature.
Preface to this story is in 2003, tragically, a scientist was actually killed.
Uh,
Kirstie Brown was doing underwater research and she was taken down by a leopard
seal and drown, which she just yanked the ice. She was swimming
and it just came up and grabbed her and took her down to 300 feet. Nonetheless,
our story starts with Paul and his guide go down there in a boat in the Arctic
Ocean looking for seals. The first seal we encountered,
I'd never seen a leopard seal before. And we came around in,
into this bay where there was a penguin colony. And right away got on,
who's seen many, many leopard seals. He said to me, you know, bloody hell,
that's the biggest seal I've ever seen.
And she came up to the boat with a penguin in her mouth.
She went underneath the boat and she started ramming the pain,
went underneath the knees, the whole of the boat,
lifting the bowel out of the water. And that's when good on looks to me.
And he says, Paul, it's time for you to get in the water. Yeah.
And his thick Swedish accent. Wow. Were you freaking out? I had dry mouth. Um,
just from the nervousness, I was trembling and you know,
I put my mask on and slipped over the 29 degree Fahrenheit water.
And uh, there she was instantly right there.
Mm.
Massive. Huge. Well, how huge. Probably over a thousand pounds. Oh my God.
12 feet long.
[inaudible]
she dropped her pain when she came right over to me and she opened up her mouth
and she engulfed the front of the camera.
Her canines were on top of my head too, or below my chin.
And I'm basically staring down her throat.
I can't believe you managed to take a picture of this because I'm looking at
this picture and these teeth are huge. The canines you, they're like massive.
So you were doing business at this moment? Yeah, I'm working at that point.
You can even see the texture of the seals.
Tongues like she has these little fibers on it. Okay.
Does 180 degree view. So he had to get that, that perspective.
I'm basically in the mouth to get that shot. Wow. So then what happened?
She backs off, looks at me, sniff my flippers, touched him with her nose,
poked me in the bum, came up and did this open mouth threat display again.
[inaudible]
and then she swims away.
Wow.
Just, I was just getting ready to swim back to the Zodiac. You know,
I've been in the water for quite awhile and I'm cold and all of a sudden she
shows up with a freshly caught life. Penguin chicken, her mouth, Huh.
And I'm sitting there staring at her and she stops about 10 feet away from me
and she's got the penguin by the feet and the penguin's flapping its flippers
trying to get away.
She lines the penguin up the face perfectly in my direction and she lets it go.
The penguins swam right by me and she chases off after it and grabs it,
comes back and does it again and again and again.
Why Gam and what was she doing?
At first I couldn't figure out what was going on.
I thought maybe she was having a hard time eating it and then it dawned on me
she was trying to feed me.
Oh,
did you make any attempt during this period to say no, thank you.
Nope. Nope. I'm so in such disbelief at this point.
I'm just trying to capture it.
Whoa.
Well,
didn't you feel compelled as a social human to just offer some kind of gestural
explanation? I mean with me, I would have made some look like com.
I don't eat that stuff. Or
maybe it's like you take, you take the penguin at that point and you're like,
well I went and some penguins swimming 15 miles an hour, you know. Oh,
so you mean when when she lets go and she goes film like a bullet. Oh,
he's pathetic because what he's saying is I'm a pathetic creature. I can't,
I actually,
I'm thinking exposures. Get the shot, keeps shooting. You're such a photo dude,
you know. Well I'm, I work for NASA.
I don't want to anthropomorphize too much.
But as the penguin was swimming by this huge seal,
she looked over at me and I swear she had a look of disgust interface.
So she goes off and gets another penguin and this penguin now is quite weak and
tired looking. And so I think she's worn it down and she lets the penguin go.
Penguin takes off,
she grabs it does out a couple more times and you're still not eating the
penguin, right?
Next encounter was bringing me dead penguins and sometimes she would just drop
off a dead penguin right on top of the camera and she would just sit there and
with this dejected look on her face staring at me.
And then she went to the stage of flipping dead penguins on top of my head and
trying to force feed me these penguins telling me at this point, you know,
eat these damn penguins. I'm trying to feed you. Why won't you eat my penguins,
eat the penguins.
And she would start to eat the penguins right in front of me and show me how to
eat them. She would rip them apart on the surface,
get the skin off them and she's stretching them in the water in front of me.
And, and how much time is passing here? I mean, we're talking minutes, hours.
This went on for four days. Four days.
And when you're in the water, you know, day after day,
what's happening for you at this point? Are you still just a guy with a camera?
I mean, I was starting to fall in love with this seal.
It's just a this animal that's just so intelligent, so a powerful,
and they could kill you in an instant. Yet you're, they mean, well,
we'll usually, you're in love what you were,
were you in love with the idea of this or did you really like her?
I really liked her. She was beautiful. She was big. She had this,
this beautiful face,
beautiful silver color to her and she kind of glow it underwater.
I'm just so in love with this seal at this point, not sleeping at night.
I have a hard time eating. I just can't wait to see her.
I can't the first thing in the morning, you know, first sign of light,
I'm in that Zodiac
[inaudible]
and then on the fourth day is when, you know, I was thinking, okay,
maybe she's weary of me and she's getting tired of me,
so I'm just going to totally leave her alone.
And that's when I started going off and presenting myself to other seals who
were swimming around the rookery and,
and I was in the water and the same big female came up to me and she started to
do all these really beautiful belly like moves.
I'm photographing her and looking at her and all of a sudden she drops her
penguin, she turns upside down and she does this big guttural Cook, Cook, Cook,
Cook, Cook, Cook, cook, this big jarring noise as vibrating my whole body.
I can really feel it in my chest. It's so loud and I'm thinking,
am I being attacked?
She'd finally told me that she is sick of me and wants me off her feeding
grounds, but as soon as she did that,
another leopard seal shot out from right behind me.
And so this leopard seal had stuck in behind me and she did that noise to chase
that seal away, a smaller seal. She chased the seal it too, had a penguin.
She grabbed its penguin and brought me that seals penguin and dropped it off in
front of me. Oh
Wow. Sarah. Lucky guy. Wow. Me Moments getting emotional. We live in that.
I mean, it's very powerful.
Have you ever been in love with an animal in quite this way before? Never.
Never. Have you ever had an experience with, uh,
with another human that Reynolds is perhaps when I was a kid with my mom,
someone taking care of you and feeling safe and nurtured and protected,
but I've never had that in my life as an adult. It sounds,
this is such an interesting species moment here. I mean,
it sounds like you're doing something if you're transgressing or something.
Sounds like you're stealing something from the gods right here,
right at this moment. I mean, I don't know what words I can find to,
to explain it. Thank you so much. Thank you guys.